Sam Alman just warned that compute might
be in a bubble, which is weird because
he's running Open AI, you know, chat
GPT. How how could you argue that while
simultaneously saying you need more
compute and you're buying Mac Studios?
So, in this segment, we're going to try
to reconcile the shift that's happening.
And I think it's really important
because it helps us explain potentially
why we are seeing some shifts in stocks
including Nvidia up 3.7% today. Cerebras
up 5% today, Dell up 9% today while at
the same time Marll is down 2%.
But more importantly, Credo is down 20%
after earnings. How do we reconcile all
of this? How could this potentially all
make sense? Well, I think it's useful to
start with what's going on with OpenAI.
And no, I don't mean the relatively
basic news that was shouted out by Elon
Musk where Elon Musk says a leopard
can't change his spots. because after
all, Elon hates Sam Holman. Here you
have uh the article that Elon Musk was
responding to where Apple is accusing
OpenAI of destroying evidence in the
lawsuit they have between each other.
That's not the issue at hand here. The
issue at hand, which just so we can
verify it, there's the Elon tweet, "A
leopard can't change its spots." That's
not the issue at hand. The issue at hand
actually has to do with this particular
interview and this about 55 minutes in
clip right here that suggests somehow
simultaneously as there being a compute
shortage there could also be a compute
uh or lack of compute- which is weird
like how do you have both at or sorry a
surplus of compute how could you have
both at the same time let's listen to
this and see how we can reconcile to
make sense of it here we go
>> astronomical numbers associated with
this that you feel is at risk at all
when you look at all of this?
>> I'm not worried about our compute
buildout plans. I am worried about the
world's compute buildout plans. Like I
think we are going to be able to use all
of the compute very profitably that we
are planning to build. Um but I am
seeing the first signs of what feels to
me like unsustainable silliness of you
know random new NeoCloud popping up.
people claiming that they're going to
build gigantic amounts of compute next
year that I think they don't have the
revenue to support or a buyer. Uh yeah,
I definitely feel like some fear about
what the world is doing as a whole.
Although I
>> or a buyer, too much compute, random Neo
clouds popping up. Let's try to
reconcile a little bit of this because
Nvidia is probably popping today on this
reportedly nearly complete $14 billion
acquisition of Hugging Face. It's about
a $ 122.9 billion acquisition plus about
a billion dollars in employee retention.
You know, got to give got to give the
employees a billion dollars just to
stick around.
A lot of people believe all of this
could be connected. What Sam just said,
Nvidia's acquisition of Hugging Face and
the Neocloud issue. So, how do we pull
this together? Well, first we have to
remember that Nvidia has got 15-year
lease commitments for some uh data
centers uh or or for some compute that
they're trying to actively pawn off on
third parties. They say this here in
this CF letter, "We signed data center
lease agreements with terms of
approximately 15 years that are expected
to commence between 2028 and 2029 uh
fiscal year. uh and we expect to
reassign those data center leases to
third parties. So given that we're in
fiscal 27 right now, this basically
means these leases are starting next
year and the year after that. They're
trying to pawn them off on third
parties, you know, maybe private credit,
but they're signing these contracts here
saying, "Hey, we'll lease a bunch of
compute."
A jaded view of the hugging face
acquisition by Nvidia is that they have
all this compute that they've just
secured and that maybe there is a little
too much compute being built. And so
Nvidia is coming in swooping some of
this surplus compute. One of the
companies they bought surplus compute
from or promised to buy surplus compute
from was Coref. And they said, "Hey, let
us know if you ever need us to buy your
surplus compute." And then they did.
Core we've said, "Yeah, we've got
surplus compute. We can't get rid of
Nvidia. You said you would guarantee it
and you would buy it. Here you go. Buy
it." So now Nvidia is like, "Great. We
just wanted to sell the chips. Now we
have compute that we don't really need.
What if we bought a business that needs
compute? Huh? Welcome to HuggingFace.
Hugging Face widely considered the
GitHub of AI. They host like 3,000
different models and they're, you know,
ARR businesses associated with hugging
face subscription models and a lot of
information about artificial
intelligence and a lot of use for
artificial intelligence. Hence why they
have a nearly 14 billion uh acquisition.
Some jaded views are that Nvidia
oversimplifying here but that Nvidia can
now utilize this power of controlling
hugging phase to guide model adoption
towards CUDA or Nvidia compute and
potentially enable or support that
varian compute with the data center
leases they have now secured. So, in
other words, you have this complete
circle. Uh, and maybe it's a jaded point
of view, but maybe that's exactly why
Nvidia is going after hugging face. And
does Sam Alman have a point about
unsustainability in the Neoclouds? The
best way to analyze that is to look at
the financials for Coree, which we'll do
in just a moment. Quick reminder, we did
extend that coupon code to Friday over
at meetke.com. So, make sure to join us
over in the alpha membership. Remember,
it could be a tax write off. You just go
to meet Kevin.com. Join us there. If you
want to bundle up the meet Kevin
membership and the reinvestomes
artificial intelligence software that
we've created, you can do that at
meetinvest.com.
You buy both of those using the same
coupon code expiring Friday. Uh if you
have any issues, just email us at
staffme.com. But that will be the last
time the lifetime subscription will be
available to lock in. So, how does that
circular nature work? And then what are
we actually seeing at Coreweave? And
what's going on with companies like
Credo? Okay, so the idea basically is if
a company like Coreweave says, "Hey,
we're going to build it and they will
come. They build a bunch of compute." If
they're only able to rent out a portion
and they can't rent out all of their
compute, uh then they don't need to buy
any more Nvidia chips. Okay? So, if this
is the unused uh portion right here, the
dark portion, we'll call it kind of like
dark fiber in the internet days, then
they end up going to Nvidia and saying,
"Look, we need you to take this over. We
need you to do something with it." Well,
now Nvidia is like, "Great. We were not
expecting to have to take that compute
so early. So, we need to put this to
work. So, what can we do?" Well, let's
buy something that needs compute or
could utilize compute. Why don't we buy
a software company like hugging face and
we can put that compute to use. Now all
of a sudden you can kind of compute
complete the cycle where the additional
jade comes in that says if you could
then guide models to be a little bit
more CUDA friendly which is that uh you
know programming layer on the uh graphic
cards that Nvidia uses massive moat uh
in the artificial intelligence space
then you could potentially drive more
compute demand to the neoclouds and kind
of complete that circle anytime they
have excess capacity
Nvidia will find a use for it. Fine.
It's obviously weird that they talk
about trying to offload this risk to
third parties and it suggests that you
don't really want this exposure. And I
don't think it's a surprise that in
their 10Q filing, they kind of
purposefully
downplay these leases. See, when you
look at this chart, they have this chart
written in here as they purposefully put
data center uh supply and capacity. In
other words, like, hey, uh, this is what
we're promising to still supply. These
are our supply commitments. Increasing
our commitments for critical components
for data centers. We're saying this is
how much we're still going to spend on
core components, high bandwidth, memory
or whatever going into these chips. Then
they purposefully try to bury this right
here. Data center leases not yet
commenced. These are those leases that
they're committing to over a 15-year
period. And because they can write this
in billions, because they're comparing
to their commitments, it doesn't
actually look like that big of a deal.
But starting next year, they literally
have a one over $1 billion. We don't
know because there's rounding because
again, they're showing this in billions.
They have over a billion dollars in data
center leases expenses coming next year.
That's a lot. So, they need a purpose
for that. Again, this is the only chart
they really show in billions uh that
that where the numbers get so tight and
small and it's fine. I get it. They've
got a lot of big revenues. It makes
sense. But a lot of other charts like we
go over here and we want to look at, you
know, gains that they have. Oh, what a
surprise. These are being shown in
millions. So, why are we trying to
minimize [laughter] those leases and
make them hide? You know, we go to the
cash flow statement. Oh, wow. It's shown
in millions, but those leases are shown
in billions because it makes the numbers
look a little smaller. Okay, so now we
kind of get the circularity of this. But
is there a point? Does Sam Alman have a
point? Because after all, the
information ran a piece on Coreweave and
they were actually pretty bullish on
Cororeweave. They argue the following.
They say that Cororeweave is the best
Neocloud buy right now. And they make
some fair fair points here. They say
they're trading at just 2.2 times
revenue. There's an opportunity for risk
tolerant investors looking to bet on the
AI boom. We've got uh 12.9 billion in
revenues coming this year. That's four
times that of Nebus, which is four times
that of IRM. We've got uh you know 1.5
gawatts of active power, another 3.7
gawatts under contract. Okay, fine. So
we've got a lot of enthusiasm that they
argue is uh coming to coreweave but they
argue is being discounted because of
customer concentration risk notably
Microsoft which is now going and buying
their own compute. So, is there a risk
that if Meta and OpenAI producing their
Jalapeno chip uh and Meta acquiring
their own hardware and Microsoft
acquiring their hardware, is it possible
that
maybe they don't need Coree and is that
the risk? They think that Coree is
diversifying away. They've got Jane
Street to sell to. Hey, there are plenty
people who are going to rent this
capacity. And maybe that's true. But I
actually think there's a bigger story
going on here because we have to somehow
consider
those data centers might need Nvidia to
buy back some of the data centers. But
if there's over supply in that compute,
why is Core or why is OpenAI
buying Mac Ultra and at the same time
Coreweave trading for a discount? Well,
I think there's a divergence that's
starting. I think what's happening uh is
the AI divergence is breaking AI into
two various different components of
chips. Uh you have specifically
enterprise inference chips and then you
have frontier inference chips. I'm not
saying training and inference, okay?
That ship is already sailed. That's old
news. We already know there's training
and then there's inference. What I'm
arguing is there's frontier inference
which is your biggest model, your fable
51s from anthropic, right? The latest
and greatest thinking models from GPT.
And then there's enterprise inference,
which is exactly what the Max Studio
Ultra would be perfect at and could
potentially argue that why would OpenAI
pay for enterprise inference if the vast
majority of agentic needs that people
have can run on a Mac Ultra? Well, then
we don't need to pay for the GB300, the
GB200 or H100s or other Blackwell chips.
We don't need these. We don't need the
Vera Rubin for that enterprise
inference. And that could potentially
explain the stock movement that we're
seeing today. Although we want to be
careful just to use a day uh in the
stock market to argue, oh, that's it.
This is definitely the trend that's
happening. But it is quite interesting
because look at the difference of these
companies. Credo, which is down 20
almost 21% today, is a supplier of data
center copper and photonics.
Cerebrus is a supplier of inference
chips that are high-speed tokenbased for
enterprises. So enterprise inference up
5.5% today. Enterprise data centers Dell
up 8% today. They don't supply the
hyperscalers. They're not trying to sell
hyperscalers Vera Rubin chips. They're
trying to go to businesses and say,
"Look, we'll get you localized data
center compute in a box, in your own
box. We'll we'll deliver the rack, the
power supply, the switching equipment,
the CPUs, the GPUs. We'll put it all
together in a box for you and we only
end up taking like a 6% net margin. So,
why do it yourself? We'll set it up for
you, and then we'll sell you our
software to go with it, so it's nice and
easy for the customer." So enterprise AI
exploding, enterprise AI inference at
least moving up today, though Cerebras
has been a little bit of a lagger. Data
center technologies like Credo slowing
on margin issues. I'll show you those in
just a moment. And then of course
Coreweave the information argues is a
buy, but then you get people like Sam
Alman bagging on them going, I don't
know, man. They might be getting a
little speculative in their buildout.
Well, this is where what's interesting
is what kind of capital uh these
companies have actually deployed. So,
you look at a core, the majority of
their chips, at least based on public
filings and reporting on this, the
majority of their chips are expected to
be uh frontier level training style
chips. Yeah, they're moving into
inference. They're moving into the RTX
6000. They moved into that last year.
Expectations are that's a very low
exposure and enterprise inference is the
next frontier. But if you're holding the
bag on a lot of frontier data center
chips, is there a debt risk that's
keeping a company like Coreweave down?
And personally, when I go look at the
core financials, I think the answer is
yes. We don't need to know that they're
losing money. Technically, that's
already old news. If you add back in
depreciation, they're making money. But
this is a return on the investment on
their cash flow, which they're spending
massive amounts of money on capex.
They're spending 14 billion on 3.6 of
operating cash flow. So, they're
obviously needing to borrow money or
raise money, which is exactly what
they're doing. Here you go. They were
they spent $14 billion on capex. They
raised $3 billion in stock and net 11
billion in financing. Fine. Companies do
this. They're trying to expand. They're
trying to invest. But the issue with
Coreweave is their balance sheet isn't
that great. Their balance sheet compared
to a company like Nbis is really poor.
If you type into YouTube meet Kevin uh
Nebius, you'll see my Nebius breakdown
and their balance sheets actually in a
pretty decent place. Coreweave, on the
other hand, they have $5.5 billion in
cash with $18 billion in bills. They
have $3 in short-term debt for every $1
of cash they have. That's not good. that
slows the build out and makes financing
more challenging, especially if Sam
Alman suggests, hey, maybe on the
frontier level, we're starting to get a
little excessive on compute. Jalapeno is
actually potentially a discounted way to
outperform some of that frontier level
compute, which then suggests you have
Jalapeno and potentially an overupp of
frontier compute that could be weighing
down the NeoClouds who are heavily
exposed to frontier level compute where
instead enterprise AI is sort of where
it's at, the next big rally. Who knows,
maybe that rally's already come. I mean,
Dell's up like 3x, right? Maybe it's too
late. But that's also where Nvidia
rejecting 227 again today is interesting
because a lot of people say, "Okay, so
Nvidia wins either way. Nvidia wins with
Frontier Compute. Nvidia wins with uh
Enterprise Compute,
does it?" Well, that's also where things
are a little blurry. See, if you
actually look and break down uh the
graphics income uh which is exactly
where Nvidia says that the graphics
segment includes GPUs for gaming and
enterprise workstations. So the
Blackwell 6000, the 5090, whatever those
are included in graphics. Graphics
revenue is broken down right here
compared to data center revenues, comput
and networking right here. We can
compare that to their operating income
for those segments and we can come up
with margins for those segments. We can
see that data centers for Nvidia are
pushing a 71% operating income margin,
which obviously explains why Nvidia
really wants to sell more data center
chips, which explains why they might
want to buy Hugging Face to kind of keep
the Neocloud supported and keep those
leases operating because they want to
keep selling data center chips because
they've got a 71% operating margin on
that. Really, really good margin. the
operating margin from the graphics side,
so gaming and workstation AI and more
enterprise AI only 49.2%.
Still really good,
but
a fraction of the 71%. I mean, in
fairness, nearly 50% operating income is
still very good. It's just a whole lot
lower than 71%. And when Nvidia
forecasts even like a 1% miss on gross
margins, people freak out and the stock
ends up falling. So the margins matter a
lot to Nvidia. So let's try to put all
of this together because there's a lot
of information here. Uh oh, after one
more thing, I got to show you the Credo
uh financials because again, remember
how I just said margins matter a lot.
Let's just do a quick look on Credo.
Take a look at this. Credo, their their
revenue goes up 9.6%. Oops. Revenue up
9.6%.
But their cost of revenue went up 22.3%.
So, their costs went up way higher than
their revenue, leading their gross
profit to only rise by 3% compared to
May. Now, in fairness, these are not
year-over-year numbers, but it shows you
a weakening from August to May when you
divide these numbers here. If I look at
sales and administrative, like what
they're spending on selling these their
hardware, you're up 43%.
The R&D part is up about uh 32%.
Which then somewhat suggests or or
sorry, they only pitch the R&D portion
and total operating expenses are up 32%.
Which is obviously way higher than their
revenue growth. So their margin really
got hit this quarter. I don't think
they're necessarily overpriced. I
actually think they're, you know, with
net margins around 50%, they're selling
relatively close to a one peg on, uh,
you know, 26% 4-year forward growth
could actually be a whole. It could be a
buying opportunity, but I think the
stock is down. I don't own it. I think
the stock is down 20% today because the
market hates when margin starts
faltering. And so if you shift to
enterprise compute, you're probably
going to see more margin weakness at
NVIDIA in the future. If you shift away
from the hyperscalers and into
enterprise compute, it's not margin
accreative to Nvidia. It hurts margin
for Nvidia. So let's put all of this
together. Let's try to simplify this
because this is a whole lot of
information. Sam Alolman is basically
saying there's excess supply in a
portion of the market. So that's the
thesis, excess supply. Our argument is
where that excess supply is being seen
based on his comments around the
Neocloud and how they're going to use
all their compute. Our argument is that
excess supply is probably in the
frontier inference. I'm not even talking
about training frontier inference level.
So he argues excess supply, we argue
it's in frontier inference. If that is
true, if that comes to bear, then yes,
Neo clouds that have a lot of exposure
to frontier inference are going to be
sad. But also in the longer term,
Nvidia's longerterm future margins are
going to be sad if you shift to
enterprise inference. the ones who win
uh well also uh a company like Credo
would be sad because you're seeing less
of those optics or cabling going into
big data centers and more going into
enterprise artificial intelligence. The
company that wins on enterprise AI right
now is Dell. The problem is how long is
that growth going to keep up? But then
again, that's what people have been
saying for the last two years. It's like
how does a company with 4% margins go to
five, go to six, go to seven, go to 8%
net margins?
Well, it's because of the AI boom, but
how long does that go? So, that's a
little bit of the warning broken down
that Sam Alman's talking about. He
doesn't specifically mention that it's
frontier inference. That's my conclusion
that there's this difference between
frontier inference and enterprise
inference and that's why we're seeing
these moves in the stock market. And as
an investor, it I've regularly been
thinking, you know, where do you move
money to get exposed to enterprise
artificial intelligence? And the real
answer is it's unless you're willing to
take the low margin plays like a Corsair
for example, which isn't exactly the
cheapest stock, but a lot of workstation
components go into a company uh or come
from a company like Corsair. power
supplies, even RAM sticks themselves.
And honestly, if you look at a company
like Corsair, IT'S IT'S BOTTOMED OUT
AROUND, you know, uh the ceasefire days
of uh the beginning of April. You know,
the puppy was trading for like $5.60.
[music] It's now trading for 12 bucks.
Corsair could be another low margin
winner, much like Dell is this low
margin winner of enterprise compute.
If you want to get out of the
infrastructure stack, then you have to
get to the value providers and that's
going to be software, which is really a
topic for a whole another video. So
that's my take on what Sam just said.
Lot of info, but I think it's quite
fascinating.
>> Why not advertise these [music] things
that you told us here? I feel like
nobody else knows about this.
>> We'll we'll try a little advertising and
see how it goes.
>> Congratulations, man. You have done so
much. People love you. People look up to
you.
>> Kevin Praath there, financial analyst
[music] and YouTuber. Meet Kevin. Always
great to get your take.